what's something that's actually  incredibly misogynistic but everyone  just didn't dress code let me explain no  dress code is one of the earliest  symptoms of rape culture in America what  is rape culture rape culture is  basically victim blaming and blaming a  woman for an assault that happens to her  you know what the standard dress code is  for men at least in formal settings we  have to wear full suits no matter the  season no matter the temperature and if  it's a wedding and Everyone likes to  have their weddings in the summer and  you're in the wedding party then that  means you're wearing a tuxedo long  sleeves jacket pants a tie choking  around your neck we're dying of heat  exhaustion in the summer we can't  breathe but we don't complain about that  men never go around this is sexist that  I have to wear a suit I don't like it